the Joe Rogan experience last just
signed their first ever transgender
boxer it's a trans female-to-male boxer
and my first thought was this guy's
gonna get lit up he goes and fights
actual men oh it was female-to-male yeah
well hope they're all amateurs I guess
maybe dude we saw its gang fest naked
rose-petal say this is it
that's a female-to-male really yep look
at the shoulders that was Andy Dick's
head like a perfect track teams to a
mixed gender races yeah really races
disaster tweeted about it yeah it's a
disaster roids yeah well the the the men
blew by the women like their part that's
how it works kids gender [ __ ] know who
you know transgender athletes you know
suffers women that's that's always women
when you're when you're trying to like
make everything diverse let's diversify
and include everyone no you're not
including everyone you're including men
to compete as women that's what you're
doing because the women competing is men
like that every last boxer and I haven't
sparred in forever I'll knock that dude
the [ __ ] out there's just no way this is
a difference there's a giant difference
though guys never gonna beat Deontay
Wilder he's never gonna beat a real
buzzer remember Andy Kaufman was full-on
challenging women wrestlers he was going
as hard as he could amazing he was going
as hard as it could there's a lot of
women jiu-jitsu people that'll [ __ ] you
up though mm-hmm but that's a different
animal you're not punching things I mean
there's a lot of female boxers it'll
[ __ ] like Claressa Shields will [ __ ] you
up
you know there's a few Ann Woolf she'll
[ __ ] a lot of men up but it's not normal
you're not gonna [ __ ] a normal man up
who weighs the same weight as them it's
just that it is not it's just not fair
it's not fair and women suffer with this
transgender athlete thing what do you
think you're gonna suffer until I figure
it out or what they well the Olympic the
weightlifting committee's already
figured it out
powerlifting committee they've already
banned transgender women they've banned
it all yeah the whatever the
organization of power lifters is but
they've put the [ __ ] kibosh on it
because all these trans women who are
[ __ ] men are breaking all these world
record your Durer how weird they're
crushing these records it's flunk is
like we want to be like okay I want to
understand your plight but at the same
time you can just kind of see it from
our point of view you are setting world
records all the time it doesn't make any
sense it's just this weird City you know
what it is it's where the rubber hits
the road when it comes to this whole
trans activism thing like this is what
it we're really like when gender
dysphoria becomes a real issue when that
when is that one physical competition
and physical altercations if a trans
woman beats the [ __ ] out of a regular
woman in a bar is it a girl beating up a
girl in a bar let's let's be honest it's
not yeah it's a male it's a biological
male beating up a female that's what it
is that is what it is and there was a
study recently released about trans
athletes in their physical performance
after you know one year of transitioning
and how much the males have lost versus
how much the females have gained female
to male gained very little male to
female lost very little really yeah very
little it's like a very small decrease
in their their overall strength after a
year of transitioning oh looks small
like below 15% Sal rageous these it's
women it's biological women getting
[ __ ] over by people who want to be a
woman that's what it is and everyone who
wants to be
oh we're diverse and we're inclusive and
you know we're progressive and what if
you went from woman to man could you
then fight against the women no if you
went from women - man you fight against
men and you know what can't you in this
new world could you fight back in the
book because you like if I'm born a
woman no I'm a man
yeah can you wear that where should I
fight you have to fight man no yes what
I'm saying under in your world in my
world yeah where they do they can't
fight if I trans people compete against
for the trans people
[Applause]